اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من الجليل الاعلى
اهلا بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن اصابه
ثمانيه جنود في الساعات الماضيه وينقل برا
اخرين اصيبوا شمالي القطاع ويسحب لوائين
من مناطق الجنوب وول ستريت جورنال تنقل عن
مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين ان نحو 80%
من انفاق غزه لا تزال
سليمه اكثر من 100
65 شهيدا على الاقل خلال 24 ساعه واستمرار
قصف محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي وحصاره مضطر
عائلات فلسطينيه لدفن
150 من ابنائها في
باحاته نتنياهو يعلن تمسكه بالحرب ويتهم
عائلات الاسرى بتاخير استعاده ابنائهم عبر
المظاهرات وينتقد الاصوات الاسرائيليه
المشكك في الانتصار وذلك بالتزامن مع
احتجاجات في تل ابيب وحيفا تهاجمه وتطالب
باستقالته وبصف لاستعاده
الاسرى اشتباكات بين مقاومين فلسطينيين
وجنود الاحتلال بعد تسلل قوات اسرائيليه
خاصه الى مخيم جنين كما اندلعت مواجهات
خلال اقتحام الاحتلال مدينه طوباس وجرت
عمليات دهم ليليه في قلقيليه وبلده الشيوخ
شمال الخليل تخللها اعتقال عدد من
الفلسطينيين جيش الاحتلال يشن غارتين على
بلدتي زبقين وحوله جنوبي لبنان ويعلن رفع
جاهزيته ويجري تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه
للواء المظليين وحزب الله يستهدف
بالصواريخ جنودا اسرائيليين قرب موقع بركه
ريشه ويؤكد تحقيق اصابات مب
الى
اللقاء